hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einem neuen mine
behinderter bruder und ich testen
irgendwas video ich lebe seit ungefähr
fünf jahren in berlin und mein bruder
hat mich in der zeit fünf mal besucht
aber immer wenn er zu besuch kamen haben
wir halt zeit in meiner wohnung
verbracht einmal sind wir zum gramm
butter torgefahr mit meinen eltern das
auch mit dem auto aber zu zweit sind wir
nie so richtig unterwegs gewesen und vor
allem ohne auto von meinen eltern und
mir ist das nie so wirklich aufgefallen
weil in meinem kopf irgendwie diese
vorstellung war ja aber mit rollstuhl
ist es ja super anstrengend oder
komplizierter als zu fuß deswegen
bleiben wir lieber zuhause und
verbringen einfach hier zu sein als
aktion menschen um die ecke kamen gesagt
hat hey wir haben das video mit seinem
bruder gesehen auf der kamelfarm hast du
nicht lust etwas zum thema inklusion zu
machen ist es mir wie schuppen von den
augen gefallen und ich dachte mir ja
will ich ich möchte mit meinem bruder
unterwegs durch berlin laufen oder
rollen und einfach mal schauen ob das
möglich ist und warum ich mich immer im
kopf nicht dazu bereit gefühlt habe denn
bei der aktion mensch aktion denn denn
bei der aktion mensch aktion kampagne
geht es darum in clenze zu sein als in
krenzer machst du dich für inklusion
starken dafür gibt es auch coole
t-shirts die mein bruder und ich auch
angezogen haben für diese ganze aktion
die könnt ihr auch gewinnen aber dazu
später mehr ich wollte das heute
eigentlich anziehen aber weil ich das
gestern mit meinem bruder schon an hatte
und meine mama abends irgendwas mit
tomatensoße gekocht hat und ich so blöd
war das t shirt noch an behalten haben
sind jetzt hier zwei tomaten flecken
drauf und ich dachte das sieht ein
bisschen blöd aus aber hier das ist das
t shirt das hatte ich gestern den ganzen
tag an als beautiful und es ist 100
prozent recycelt das heißt das wäre
eigentlich müde gewesen aber jetzt wurde
ein t shirt draus gemacht und ich hab
von aktion mensch auf ganz tolle
postkarten bekommen und einen beutel und
einen netten brief und das zeige ich
euch hashtag in krems inklusion ist wie
toleranz nur kratzer und falls euch der
begriff in karenz oder nicht sagt hier
sind mal gut beschrieben influenza der
substantiv maske wortkombination aus dem
englischen verb to influence
beeinflussen und inklusion soziologie
menschen die sich aktiv für das
selbstverständliche miteinander aller
menschen einsetzen und ich finde wir
alle sollten in tänzer sein inklusion
first café second aber nur aus der bts
tasse für mich es ist eine absolute
selbstverständlichkeit dass ich menschen
mit behinderung und ohne behinderung
gleich behandeln egal wer sie sind woher
sie kommen wie sie aussehen
natürlich liegt es daran dass ich durch
die geschichte meines bruders ja auch
damit lernen musste umzugehen
beziehungsweise schon früh angefangen
habe mich mit dem thema zu beschäftigen
wenn man sich aber nicht damit
beschäftigt bzw wenn man nicht damit
aufgewachsen ist und noch kein kontakt
hatte zu menschen mit behinderungen
vielleicht nur keine ahnung mal jemanden
auf der anderen straßenseite gesehen hat
dann ist das ja nicht schlimm
nur man sollte trotzdem sich darüber
bewusst sein dass man keinen unterschied
machen sollte in einer gesellschaft die
inklusion als etwas selbstverständliches
ansieht sollte es möglich sein für
jemanden zum beispiel im rollstuhl ganz
normal und einfach zur arbeit zu kommen
wie jeder andere auch und das wollte ich
mit meinem bruder test für mich ist es
natürlich selbstverständlich rauszugehen
in die bahn zu steigen und irgendwohin
zu fahren egal wo es ist wie lange es
dauert wie viele treppen auf mich warten
mit meinem bruder allerdings war das
alles ein bisschen schwieriger gibt eine
web wo man schauen kann wo man mit dem
rollstuhl gut hinkommen kann wo nicht
und wo es ein bisschen schwieriger ist
und ich finde es wirklich traurig dass
immer noch so viele rote punkte
angezeigt werden wo man mit dem
rollstuhl nicht hinkommt zum beispiel
der bahnhof den ich immer benutze ist
für rollstuhlfahrer nicht geeignet denn
dafür nur treppen hin ist schon öfter
vorgekommen dass ich mit dabei geholfen
habe den kinderwagen hoch zu tragen aber
ich habe mir noch nie
die gedanken darüber gemacht dass jemand
im rollstuhl einfach diesen bahnhof
nicht benutzen kann als ich aber mit
meinem bruder zum alexanderplatz fahren
wollte habe ich gemerkt es ging deswegen
mussten wir leider zum nächsten bahnhof
lauf und bestand ist mir auch noch nie
aufgefallen wie schwer eigentlich dieser
weg ist überall gab es stolperfallen und
das den ganzen weg bis zum bahnhof aber
mein bruder hat er zum glück nicht
starke schwester und ich hab's
hingekriegt dass wir da nicht fahren
können zürich ohne rampe für wisse aber
es ist eine challenge ich mein
komponieren
es beginnt auf ansage freunde auch wenn
es dreimal fast zum unfall kam
ich weiß nicht ob wir es auf kamera
haben aber an einer stelle sind wir
gefahren da war so ein großes loch oder
hat gar nicht so groß ist welcher drum
herum gefahren es war also schnell und
einfach so und plötzlich bleibt der
rollstuhl stecken und mein bruder fliegt
wirklich ein nach vorne und wieder
zurück ich habe mich so erschrocken und
mein bruder auch zum glück ist nichts
passiert
[Gelächter]
da habe ich auch gedacht wie kann das
denn sein natürlich mit meinen füßen ist
das kein problem da laufe ich drüber
oder knicke zum aber das passt schon
wohl wenn du jetzt auch älter bist das
war nicht cool so an das hat überhaupt
alexa schaffen
roman von peter wollen dann sind wir
beim zweiten bahnhof angekommen ich
schon ein bisschen verschwitzt mein
bruder ordentlich durchgerüttelt und was
sehen wir dort
[Musik]
postkarten fahrstuhl der fahrstuhl ist
nicht euer ernst
ich kann euch nicht sagen wie frustriert
ich war als wir dort angekommen sind und
das einzige was uns vom bahnfahren so
abgehalten hat dieser kaputte fahrstuhl
war ich mein wir sind schon eine station
extra gelaufen und dann ist dieser
fahrstühle können kaputt gehen aber man
kann sie auch repariert und wenn man
schon ein schild dranhängen kann dass
dieser fahrstuhl kaputt ist kann man
dann welchen weg ich weiß es vom sonntag
aber manche leute brauchen so ein
fahrstuhl und mir ist es nie vorher
aufgefallen wie so ein fahrstuhl
reparatur was dauert es fünf minuten
unseren schwestern keine ahnung doch
vorher war stelle schon mal kaputt waren
ich habe mich noch nie mit spielen
beschäftigt außer wenn ich mal was
schweres getragen habe dann habe ich mal
ein fahrstuhl benutzt aber sonst aber
zurück zur geschichte
wir sind dann zum nächsten bahnhof
gelaufen das war der bahnhof ostkreuz
wir sind mit dem fahrstuhl hoch zu den
ganzen gleisen wollten mit einem
fahrstuhl runter aber ratet mal dieser
fahrstuhl war auch kaputt
nee nee nein die einzige möglichkeit zu
diesem zeitpunkt hat mein bruder schon
die hoffnung verloren er dachte wir
werden jetzt einfach nach hause gehen er
hat sich nicht mehr aufgeregt ich weiß
auch nicht wie mein bruder bis heute so
ein toller mensch sein kann sich nie
aufregt oder beschwert aber ja er hat
einfach sagen dass man gesagt na ja gut
dann halt nicht so dann klappt das halt
nicht und ich dachte mir so nein also
nein wir müssten doch in die innenstadt
kommen wir sind in berlin das ist die
deutsche hauptstadt wir werden doch
wundert einen rollstuhl in die
innenstadt kommen zum glück standen da
gleich so db sicherheitsbeauftragte die
habe ich dann gefragt wie wir denn jetzt
zum gleis 4 und 5 kommt wir mussten
einen anderen fahrstufe unternehmen um
mit einem anderen spar stuhl wieder rauf
um dort wechseln und dort noch mal
runter zu fahren
[Musik]
wie viele fahrschulen wert genommen
haben die tour angekommen und man ein
bahngeleisen zu kommen
[Musik]
dann waren wir da haben es geschafft
waren wir am gleis ich habe es nicht
geglaubt dass das noch passiert aber
ganz geschafft von hier haben wir die
erfahrung auch besser wir haben uns zur
fahrtrichtung ganz nach vorne gestellt
damit der schaffner und die rampe
hinstellen kann was er auch gemacht hat
sofort und gefragt hat bis wohin wir
fahren
das fand ich super nett ich war wirklich
froh über so einen netten schaffner
glaube aber ich habe noch nie nicht
netten schaffner gesehen ich glaube
jeder der eine bahn fährt ist einfach
nett das hat auch alles sehr gut
funktioniert und ich bin in der bahn
fast in tränen ausgebrochen weil mein
bruder sich so darüber gefreut hat
einfach bahn zu fahren er hat das also
elf jahren glaube ich seit dem unfall
hatte es war einmal in der bahn
[Musik]
das war jetzt haben wir bekommen sind
all die ritte dritter war aber eine rote
karte
bahnfahren ist mal bei mir ist lange her
dass heinrich besondere
schon nach
darauf
und ich hatte so ein schlechtes gewissen
bekommen weil es kann doch nicht sein
dass ich irgendwie mit meinem bruder
noch nie mit der bahn unterwegs war und
es war so eine schöne erfahrung und er
hat sich wirklich gefreut als wir dann
am alexanderplatz angekommen sind war
der schaffner ein bisschen savage drauf
weil er gesagt dass wir keine rampe
brauchen ich glaube er war ein bisschen
faul ist aber nicht so schlimm der hat
er bestimmt viel zu tun es war sonntag
kein problem und weil ich mich nicht
getraut hat ohne die rampe über diese
marke gap between platform and rain
da habe ich mich nicht getraut den
rollstuhl rüber zu machen also hat er
schafft das für mich gemacht was ich
super nett fand und ab dann habe ich
auch gemerkt was geht also man braucht
nicht unbedingt die rampe glaube die
rampe braucht man wenn man wirklich so
riesengroß
also müsst ihr diese großen automatisch
ja und dann waren wir am alexanderplatz
[Applaus]
am alexanderplatz angekommen und was
machen wir jetzt erster schöner bieten
wir auf jeden fall ein berlin sowie hier
kaufen
irgendwie so was möchtest du denn eine
tasse ein fernsehturm
transition einmal fernsehturms mitnehmen
will ob nachfahren des kochen und als
mein bruder gesagt hat dass sie ein
bisschen kalt ist habe ich so ein
schlechtes gewissen bekommen dass wir
sofort eine mütze und handschuhe gekauft
haben die handschuhe waren leider viel
zu klein aber muss er halt frieren im
souvenirladen hat es auf jeden fall
gepasst mit dem rollstuhl dabei genug
platz und beim saturn leute da gab es
einen fahrstuhl
da gab es genug platz das war alles
wunderbar wir haben mein bruder endlich
bluetooth kopfhörer geholt weil immer
wenn ich ihn anrufe dann hat er noch
normale kopfhörer zum handy
angeschlossen das problem war aber immer
dass er ja nicht sehen kann und dann aus
versehen mal das kabel mit seiner hand
so weg gemacht hat und die kopfhörer
halt rausgefallen sind und dann musste
erst noch meine eltern rufen dass sie
mit kopfhörer wieder rein machen mussten
sie das mal vorsichtig irgendwie so und
jetzt haben wir das problem nicht mehr
jetzt haben wir bluetooth kopfhörer er
kann sich bewegen wie er möchte und
diese debatten haben einen tollen sound
und meine eltern haben sich sehr gefreut
hätte ich meinen bruder so ein tolles
geschenk gemacht haben ich bin halt aus
dem und die beste schwester der welt so
wurde ich aber geboren
ich bin einfach toll ja das hat alles
super geklappt und dann sind wir noch zu
dm und haben meinen eltern
adventskalender gekauft weil wir die
allerbesten kinder auf der welt sind und
manchmal wir haben so lange zum
alexanderplatz gebraucht dass wir halt
nicht mehr so richtig zeit hatten
deswegen konnten wir nichts anderes mehr
machen
eigentlich wollen wir uns auch in einem
café setzen und gucken ob das auch so
einfach ist wie beim saturn kopfhörer
kaufen
aber dafür hatten wir keine zeit mehr
denn meine mama hat schon mittagessen
gekocht oder abendessen und deswegen
mussten wir dann auch schon nach hause
aber auf dem nachhauseweg hatten wir
eine überraschung denn es gab einen
mauerfall film der auf dem
alexanderplatz auf so ein gebäude
projiziert wurde denn falls ihr es nicht
wusste das ist 30 jahre her seit die
mauer gefallen ist
und zu diesem anlass gab es dieses video
und das war total schön da mit meinem
bruder einfach zu stehen ganz
selbstverständlich auf dem alex und sich
das anzugucken nachdem wir so ein
bisschen shoppen waren zusammen und das
hat mich wirklich berührt bei mir in dem
moment klar wurde dass ich selber so
eine barriere im kopf hatte die dort
einfach gebrochen und ich gemerkt habe
dass auch wenn es ein bisschen
schwieriger ist berlin sich echt noch
ein bisschen verbessern kann es trotzdem
so schön ist mit meinem bruder an ganz
normalen tag zu verbringen und nicht
irgendwie nur in der wohnung rumzuhängen
weil man irgendwie glaubt soja ich jetzt
halt einfacher und ja einfach etwas zu
machen wissen spaß macht und vor 30
jahren ist die mauer gefallen und heute
es ist zeit dass die mauer in unserem
kopf fällt ja das habe ich mir
ausgedacht denn wenn es eine sache gibt
die uns alle verbindet ist dass wir
menschen sind egal wie alt wir sind egal
wie groß oder klein wir sind egal was
für handicaps wir haben ob wir der beste
athlet sind oder die langsamste schnecke
oder nur ein arm oder ein bein haben es
ist egal wir sind alles menschen so und
so sollten wir auch lernen uns zu
behandeln wir brauchen nicht erst
invasion von außerirdischen damit wir
wissen dass wir eine spezies sind die
zusammen gehört und sich gegenseitig
beschützen muss sondern wir können es
auch so einfach in köln zu sein denn
wenn unsere generation jetzt damit
anfängt inklusion als etwas völlig
selbstverständliches zu sehen dann sehe
ich für die zukunft keine probleme also
außer die pausen anderen aber um die
kümmern wir uns auch noch das alles zu
seiner zeit ich hoffe mein bruder und
ich konnten euch mit diesem video ein
paar aha momente geben oder einfach nur
das herz erwärmen und schöneren tag
bereiten wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder und jetzt gibt's was zu gewinnen
und zwar dieses t shirt und wie jedes
gewinnen könnt erfahrt ihr in meiner
instagram story also geht jetzt über
instagram und ja ich hoffe euch das
video fand wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder danke aktion mensch dass ich
teil dieser kooperation sein darf mir
bedeutet ist sehr viel und mein bruder
hat es sehr gefallen
also hängt die very much is